Trascrizione: Isabelle Andrieu
Revisore: Claudia Di Lorenzo
Quando veniamo a conoscenza di un segreto,
generalmente stupiamo
i bambini dicendo loro,
"Me l'ha detto un uccellino".
E in realtà chi è soltanto capace
di ripetere le stesse cose
viene in genere additato
più o meno come un pappagallo.
Secondo la cultura contadina,
le rondini sono degli animali sacri,
invece la civetta
è portatrice di sventura.
In Mozambico,
alcune tribù hanno imparato
a dialogare con i passeri
per andare con loro alla ricerca di miele.
Figure come Icaro,
piuttosto che Leonardo da Vinci
si sono ispirate al volo degli uccelli
e hanno sognato
di poter finalmente volare.
I corvi della Nuova Caledonia
hanno una capacità
di astrazione incredibile.
Loro si fabbricano,
utilizzando rametti e foglie,
gli strumenti necessari
per andare alla ricerca di cibo.
Ora, questo presuppone
una capacità cognitiva enorme.
Perché? Perché in realtà lo sanno fare
semplicemente per aver visto
altri corvi utilizzare gli strumenti,
ovvero sanno costruire
i loro strumenti di lavoro
pur non avendo mai visto
il processo necessario
a poterli fabbricare.
Questo fenomeno è interessantissimo,
perché permette l'evoluzione stessa
degli strumenti di lavoro
e anche l'evoluzione stessa
della specie dei corvi.
E in realtà questo fenomeno
si riteneva solo un puro appannaggio
della specie umana.
E basandomi su questo
che vi chiedo di frugare
all'interno della vostra borsa TED,
cercate, guardate dentro,
c'è una piccola busta.
Ok? Su cui c'è scritto,
"Aspetta ad aprire".
Dentro questa busta ci trovate
sei mattoncini colorati.
Siccome, appunto vi ho detto,
i corvi sanno fabbricarsi
i loro strumenti pur non avendo mai visto
le istruzioni necessarie a poterlo fare,
l'esperimento che faremo qui dentro
è di cercare di fare la stessa cosa.
Pensate ad una papera.
Voi avete mai visto una papera dal vivo?
Se non l'avete vista dal vivo,
di sicuro l'avete vista
in qualche documentario,
l'avete vista nei cartoni animati,
l'avete vista nei fumetti, ok?
Com'è fatta una papera?
Come sono fatte le sue zampe,
com'è fatto il suo petto, il suo collo?
Vola o non vola una papera?
Immaginatela, costruitela
nella vostra mente.
Ora vi chiedo con i sei pezzettini,
con i sei mattoncini
che avete tra le mani,
di costruire una papera.
Non copiate dai vostri vicini.
Vi do tempo più o meno un minuto.
Montate i vostri sei mattoncini
e costruite una papera. Prego.
Quando avete finito di costruirla,
sollevatela in alto,
così posso vedere chi ha finito.
Ora vi chiedo un po' di attenzione,
perché questa parte
è estremamente divertente.
Allora, osservate.
Osservate le vostre papere,
osservate le papere dei vostri vicini.
Tenetele su, tenetele su.
Ci sono papere uguali?
I vostri vicini hanno fatto
delle papere uguali alla vostra?
(Trambusto)
So che vi ho fatto fare
è un esercizio estremamente interessante,
ovvero vi ho fatte costruire una papera,
non vi ho dato le istruzioni
per poterlo fare,
vi ho chiesto di osservare le papere,
non vi ho detto che poteva esistere
una papera giusta e una papera sbagliata,
e probabilmente, se le osservassimo bene,
gran parte delle papere all'interno
di questo teatro sono diverse tra di loro.
Ok?
In realtà, ciò che vi ho chiesto
di fare è qualcosa di più.
Vi ho chiesto di sfruttare
il vostro modello mentale di papera.
Tutti voi avete in testa
un modello mentale
di che cosa sia una papera,
ovvero avete osservato
le papere nella realtà.
Le papere nella realtà
sono molteplici, ok?
Ci sono papere di tanti tipi diversi,
ma voi li avete sintetizzate
nella vostra testa
e semplificate in un modello.
Ora, il vostro modello
non contiene tutti
i dettagli di una papera.
Non sapete esattamente
quante piume ha una papera, non lo so,
ma il vostro modello è sufficiente
da poter distinguere una papera
da un airone o da un gallo.
Ora ci sono persone che innovano
esattamente come avete fatto voi,
ovvero sanno osservare la realtà,
si rendono conto
che la realtà è molteplice
e riescono a sintetizzare
in testa dei modelli
che gli permettono di produrre
a loro volta dei prodotti o dei servizi
da consegnare all'umanità
che siano nuovi, che siano mai visti prima
e soprattutto che migliorino la vita
degli esseri umani.
La creatività spinge in questo,
la vostra creatività vi ha portato a fare
un numero altissimo di papere diverse.
Ora vi faccio fare un esercizio in più.
Questo disegno è uno
dei tanti studi di Pablo Picasso
in cui ha cercato
di studiare e semplificare
il modo in cui potesse essere
rappresentata la realtà
e tramite un semplice tratto,
una semplice linea,
è riuscito a produrre
quello che effettivamente
può essere facilmente
identificato come un gallo.
Ok? Ora che processo è questo?
È un processo di
ulteriore semplificazione.
I modelli mentali sono comodissimi
perché ci permettono davvero,
da un semplice tratto,
da un semplice dettaglio,
di poter decifrare la realtà.
Ci sono persone
che innovano in questo modo,
ovvero sanno guardare
nel profondo delle cose,
o meglio sanno guardare
nel profondo dell'animo delle persone.
Sanno cogliere qual è
l'essenza dei vostri sogni,
qual è l'essenza
di ciò che vi piace di più,
qual è l'essenza della felicità
e la riescono a sintetizzare
in qualcosa che chiamiamo comunemente
un'icona, ovvero un prodotto, un servizio,
un qualcosa che utilizzate
e che riconoscete da un semplice tratto.
Rendiamo più complicato e divertente
il nostro esercizio.
Se vi avessi chiesto
di costruire una non papera,
che cosa avreste costruito?
Sareste partiti da un progetto
o avreste cominciato a muovere le mani?
Aumento la difficoltà:
se vi avessi chiesto
di spiegare al vostro vicino di posto
che cosa sia un aeroplano
e lui non l'avesse mai visto?
Gli avreste detto: "Un aeroplano
è più o meno simile ad una papera".
Può avere lo stesso colore di una papera,
vola più o meno come una papera,
non fa l'uovo.
Quindi a volte cerchiamo di utilizzare
i modelli mentali per spiegare agli altri
qualcosa che loro non hanno mai visto.
Aumento la difficoltà:
se vi avessi chiesto di raccontare
al vostro vicino di posto
un qualcosa che non esiste nella realtà,
ma che vorreste fare
perché è il vostro prodotto innovativo.
Che cosa gli avreste raccontato?
Beh, la difficoltà aumenta.
È difficile pensare nella vostra testa,
decifrare ciò che state pensando,
ed è ancora più difficile
raccontarlo agli altri
o farvi aiutare dagli altri.
Ci sono persone
che innovano in questo modo,
ovvero riescono a concepire
nella loro testa
prodotti, servizi, innovazioni così nuove
da essere non soltanto
difficili da pensare
ma anche difficili
da raccontare agli altri.
Ora, come fanno queste persone?
Come fanno a riuscire
a portare a bordo altre persone?
Come fanno a raccontare tutto questo?
Beh, sono persone che hanno capito appieno
come funzionano i nostri tempi.
Sono persone che li sanno cavalcare.
Sono persone cha hanno capito
che il cambiamento
è la misura dei tempi di oggi.
Perché?
Perché i tempi di oggi
sono caratterizzati dalla velocità.
Che cosa significa "tempi veloci"?
Tempi veloci sono tempi
in cui ti sembra sempre,
perennemente di essere in ritardo, certo.
O sono quei tempi per cui chi si trova
a dover fare prodotti e servizi
arriva sul mercato
sempre un po' troppo tardi.
Se i nostri tempi sono veloci,
ci hanno anche permesso
di renderci conto di un'altra cosa,
ovvero che i tempi
in cui viviamo sono non lineari.
Che cosa significa non lineari?
Ve lo spiego con un esempio.
Provate a pensare ai vostri nonni,
quanti cambiamenti epocali
avranno vissuto nella loro vita.
Certo alcuni cambiamenti
vissuti dai vostri nonni
probabilmente sono stati davvero epocali
e stravolgenti per l'intera umanità.
Davvero impattanti.
Ma quanti in tutto? Forse cinque?
Forse dieci nella loro vita?
I loro nonni quanti ne avranno vissuti?
Forse di meno.
Ora pensate a voi,
pensate ai vostri figli.
Gli analisti dicono
che nei prossimi 20 anni,
il genere umano cambierà
più di quanto non abbia fatto
negli scorsi 300.
Quindi che cosa significa
che il nostro tempo è non lineare?
Significa che non segue
a tutti i costi una linea retta.
La linea retta è quella che ti fa pensare
che domani andrà più o meno
come oggi e come ieri.
Ma è chiaro a tutti che alcune linee
non sono rette, sono esponenziali,
se non addirittura completamente
imprevedibili e impreviste.
I nostri tempi, poi, sono complessi.
Che cosa significa complesso?
"Complesso" significa
che la quantità di relazioni tra le parti
è talmente alta da non
permetterci di semplificare.
È complessa la natura:
pensate alla foresta,
pensate agli ecosistemi naturali.
È complesso il corpo umano,
è complesso il nostro cervello.
Non è così facile,
non è neppure possibile
isolare una parte e semplificare.
Ora, ciò che è importante
all'interno della complessità
è che appunto le reti e le relazioni
ne sono la misura
davvero importante e interessante.
E ultima cosa, i nostri tempi
sono caratterizzati dall'imprevedibilità.
Ora, l'imprevedibilità
è sempre stata considerata,
o è spesso stata considerata
dalle nostre aziende
come un qualcosa di negativo.
Abbiamo cercato di pianificare ogni cosa,
ci ha sempre spaventato
pensare che il futuro sia imprevedibile.
In realtà l'imprevedibilità
è un buonissimo motore di innovazione.
Ce lo racconta Darwin,
ci racconta che è l'imprevedibilità
a permettere alle specie di evolversi
e di adattarsi al mondo
in cui stiamo vivendo.
Ora quindi come fare?
Io nella mia esperienza ho avuto modo
di incontrare centinaia di imprenditori
che si stanno facendo questa domanda.
Alcuni hanno capito come fare,
altri non lo sanno, alcuni ci riescono,
altri non ci riescono.
Tutti riconoscono
che è estremamente difficile,
ma c'è un'altra cosa
che invece io riconosco in tutti loro
e sono due caratteristiche
che accomunano le persone
che cercano di innovare oggi,
e sono una deliberata, sconfinata,
un desiderio fortissimo,
una voglia fortissima
di poter fare sperimentazione,
e di nuovo un deliberato e sconfinato
desiderio fortissimo di poter disimparare.
Che cosa significano queste due cose?
Ora, ci siamo detti,
"Il mondo di oggi, i nostri tempi
sono caratterizzati dall'incertezza
e l'incertezza è una misura positiva
dei nostri tempi".
Se sei incerto che cosa puoi fare?
Come ti puoi comportare?
Cosa puoi fare, se non puoi
prevedere sempre tutto?
Un'idea buona è cominciare
a scommettere, anziché promettere;
e per scommettere bene,
una buona idea è di cominciare
a muoverci un passo dopo l'altro.
Ovvero, faccio un piccolo passo
verso la direzione
in cui penso di voler andare,
poi mi chiedo come sta andando.
Se mi chiedo come sta andando,
lo chiedo anche agli altri.
Questo capite che presuppone
una estrema gentilezza
nei confronti di noi stesse
e delle altre persone,
ovvero devo davvero accettare
di domandarmi come sta andando.
Ora non vi sto dicendo
che tutto è allo sbando,
davvero non vi sto dicendo
che andare a caso è più o meno
come muoversi con un obiettivo,
ma vi sto dicendo che gli obiettivi
si raggiungono per piccoli passi
tramite i quali continuare a imparare.
Questa cosa dell'imparare
è un secondo termine
estremamente importante,
ovvero per anni abbiamo trasformato
le nostre organizzazioni
in learning organisations,
cioè abbiamo cominciato a pensare
che imparare fosse una misura buona
per poterci muovere
nei nostri tempi, ed è vero.
Per fortuna è stato così,
per fortuna ci siamo resi conto
che imparare è importante,
ma ad un certo punto è anche successo,
e lo fanno alcune
delle aziende con cui lavoro,
che tutto ciò che avevano imparato,
chiamateli data o chiamateli big data,
tutto ciò che avevano imparato
ogni tanto gli ha fatto pensare
di poter predire il futuro.
L'uomo da sempre ha sperato
di poter predire il futuro;
ma in realtà predire il futuro,
lo sappiamo, non si può fare.
Non riusciamo neppure
a predire che tempo farà domani,
per cui probabilmente,
anziché concentrarvi
su come diventare learning organisation,
ciò che vi voglio proporre
è di concentrarvi su come diventare
unlearning organisation,
ovvero a volte è più difficile
disimparare che imparare.
Disimparare significa spostarsi
in una condizione di leggero disagio.
Guardare il mondo,
guardare le cose che stai facendo
e renderti conto che forse
ciò che avevi imparato
per ieri e per oggi,
oggi non vale più per domani,
ovvero non puoi riapplicare
vecchie regole a mondi nuovi
e disimparare fa spazio
a un nuovo imparare.
Serve molto coraggio per poterlo fare.
È davvero una sfida entusiasmante
per il mondo dell'imprenditoria
ma anche per il mondo,
al di fuori del mondo del lavoro.
Magari ciò che fate normalmente
nella vostra vita
portatelo nel vostro mondo del lavoro,
perché lo lasciate confinato
allo spazio al di fuori del vostro lavoro?
Ora, la domanda importante per tutti noi
però è quella che ci siamo
fatti all'inizio,
ovvero, voi che tipo di innovatori siete?
Siete innovatori che guardano il mondo
e riconoscono quanto è variopinto
e sanno aggiungere prodotti nuovi
per creare ancora più felicità
o siete innovatori che sanno guardare
nel profondo dell'essere umano
e riconoscerne i tratti fondamentali
che accomunano tutte le persone
e produrre quelle che chiamiamo
appunto delle icone.
Siete innovatori
che sanno fare esperimenti?
Sapete sperimentare ed essere gentili
nei confronti dei risultati
dei vostri esperimenti?
O siete innovatori che sanno disimparare
e che quindi ogni tanto
riconoscono di poter lasciare alcune
vecchie tradizioni
per far spazio a nuove idee
e nuove modalità.
Qualsiasi tipo di innovatori voi siate,
il motivo per cui lo fate è importante.
Ovvero, nella mia esperienza
vedo innovatori che in genere
non innovano solo per sé stessi
e non innovano neppure
per l'innovazione fine a sé stessa.
Non innovi solo
per modificare dei processi
e non innovi neppure soltanto
per guadagnare di più.
Il motivo principale per cui innovi
è la linfa vitale dell'innovazione,
è la quantità di relazioni
che hai saputo creare attorno a te.
È la linfa che ti spinge a voler innovare
ed è anche la misura
di quanto bravo sei stato a farlo.
Più relazioni hai, più innoverai,
e più relazioni hai, più hai innovato.
Non è mai esistito prima, un periodo,
un momento migliore
per poter fare innovazione
e in realtà, se non mi credete,
ritirate su le vostre papere
che avete costruito.
Ascoltate questa cosa,
ascoltate il sorriso che vi è nato
sul volto quando le avevate costruite,
ascoltate il sorriso che è nato
sul volto delle persone
che le avevano costruite vicino a voi.
Ecco, questa è la misura
di quanto oggi valga la pena di innovare
e creare nuove relazioni.
Grazie.
(Applausi)